The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational research for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: I'm
open for questions
as always on every
aspect, or comments
on every aspect of the course.
Yeah?
The MATLAB problem, yes.
I better remember what
that MATLAB problem is.
So it's solving the equation
-u''+Vu' equal some delta
function halfway along?
And I chose boundary
conditions like those
so that this gets replaced by a
matrix K over delta x squared.
And this term is V times
some centered difference.
I don't know whether I should
use C. We called C, earlier
in the book, C was a circulant.
This is a centered first
difference over delta x
equal right-hand side.
All that multiplies the
discrete solution u.
I didn't get that very
well for the camera.
Maybe I'll say it again.
We have the second difference
that corresponds to -u''.
And V times the first difference
that corresponds to Vu'.
And then, the problem is--
So the physical problem is,
what happens as V gets larger?
V grows.
How does the solution
change as V increases?
So it's a very
practical problem.
The V measures the importance
of this convection,
the velocity of the fluid.
Then n, which is, well maybe
delta x is 1/(n+1), maybe.
So that we would have n
interior points and we know
the boundary values.
So the question is how do we
interpret this increasing n?
I guess we expect more
and more accuracy, right?
As n increases, delta
x getting smaller.
Our idea is that this should
be a better and better
approximation to the
differential equation.
The question about the
eigenvalues of this matrix,
I don't know exactly the answer.
So the eigenvalues, did you
discover that the eigenvalues
suddenly, they change?
They're real for small
values of V and n.
But then there's some point
at which they become complex.
And a point that involves both
V and delta x actually, V and n.
It's kind of interesting.
I guess at this moment,
interesting is the key word.
So what is the
physics going on here?
So I have a 1-D flow
and it's blocked
by these boundary
conditions are sort
of blocking it at both ends.
And I'm looking
for a steady state.
And I'm feeding in
this source here.
So I'm feeding in a
source halfway along.
So I think that would be right.
Now what's going
to happen roughly?
This term is, I think,
flowing to the right.
So it's going to carry, suppose
this was smoke or particles
or whatever.
This is like an
environmental differential
equation or a chemical
engineering equation.
Just oh, and more and
more applications.
So I think of it as this term
is carrying the flow with it.
Like, that way.
So I'm expecting your solutions
to be larger on this side.
And how do we get any
action at all on the left?
That comes from the diffusion.
The particles, when they enter,
get carried away, and faster
and faster as V increases.
But at the same
time they diffuse,
they bounce back and forth.
And some bit of
it goes this way.
But not a lot.
I'm guessing that the solution
would have a profile that
would be kind of small.
And then there's whatever jump
there has to be here, and then
larger there.
Oh, but then I have
to get it to zero.
It's a strange situation.
And maybe I'll take this
chance to mention it.
What happens as V gets
really, really large?
You could say okay, as
V gets extremely large,
forget that term.
This is the important term.
Vu' equals that.
Which we could easily solve.
But this equation
with just this term
is only first order, right?
It only has a first derivative.
And how many boundary
conditions would we
expect to have if I gave
you, if this wasn't here
and I gave you just a
first order equation?
One.
And we've got two.
Which we're imposing.
So this sort of
limit as V increases,
it produces something
called a boundary layer.
The solution is forced
to satisfy these boundary
conditions.
One of them, it's
quite happy about.
The other one, it didn't
really want to satisfy.
It only satisfied them
because, I had two
originally with this part.
But as this takes
over, the struggle
to satisfy that second boundary
condition that it really
doesn't want to
satisfy is resolved
by something, a
layer that just makes
a sort of exponential correction
at the boundary to get
to where it's supposed to go.
So, anyway.
This is a model problem
that has boundary layers.
Those are terrifically
important in aerodynamics,
you have layers around
the actual aircraft.
So lots of physics and
computational science
is hiding in this
type of example.
So those are a few words.
But not an answer
to your question.
I guess I'm happy if
you, for example, let
me know where the eigenvalues
change from real to complex.
I mean, it happens,
but you can probably,
if you look at the
matrix, you can
see what happens at the point
where that change takes place.
That's some comments.
And with the MATLAB, pure
MATLAB part, I guess I'm hoping,
and the graders are hoping,
that by providing a code
we'll get a pretty
systematic set of answers
for the requested V equal,
what was it, 3 and 12 maybe,
or something.
And the requested n, delta x's.
So I'm hoping that
everybody's graph
is going to look pretty
similar for those requests.
And then if you could do a
little exploration yourself
and make that a fifth
page, or really less
than a page, about take
V larger, take n larger,
what happens?
I'm very happy.
Or any direction.
I mean, just think of
it as a mini-project
to do the requested
ones and then
to do a little experimentation.
I'll just be interested
about anything you observe.
So there's no right
answer to that part.
Is that any help
with the MATLAB?
Let me just say, since
you showed up today,
if you have trouble
with the MATLAB
and you need Peter's
help at noon Friday
it would be okay to turn in
the MATLAB later on Friday.
I shouldn't say that.
But I just did.
So there you are.
Right.
I mean, this course,
as you've begun to see,
I know that you have lots
of demands on your time.
And sometimes you
have job interviews.
All sorts of stuff.
Conferences that
you have to go to.
We deal with that.
So just give me the
homeworks as soon as you can.
If you're ready Friday at
class time, that's perfect.
If are stuck on
MATLAB and you want
to go to Peter's discussion,
which follows the Friday
class in here, that's fine too.
So that's some thoughts
about the MATLAB
and it's partly open-ended.
What about lots of other
things in this course?
Homework came in.
How was the homework?
Maybe I just take
this chance to ask.
Was it a reasonable length?
The homework three, the pset?
Not too bad?
I will be able to post solutions
because several people are
contributing typed
solutions that could go
on on the
math.mit.edu/cse website.
Or they could also
go on our 18.085
website for this semester.
Good.
Okay, help me out
with some questions.
Thanks.
So the question is
about element matrices.
In lecture 8, I guess it was,
where we were assembling this,
I used the word that's used
by finite element people,
we were assembling K.
And one way to do it
was to multiply
the three matrices.
But that's not how
it's actually done.
It's actually assembled
out of small matrices.
Maybe small K would
be the right--
So this would be a K_element.
Out of smaller element matrices.
So for example, what's
the element matrix for,
one for each spring in this
particular problem of springs
and masses.
So let me draw some springs,
some masses, some springs,
another mass, more
springs, fixed,
not fixed, whatever,
maybe fixed-free
the way I've drawn it there.
So here's a spring with
spring constant c_2.
And we could look
at the contribution
to the whole matrix coming
from this piece of the problem.
This was actually, the
finite element method
has a wonderful
history of people,
and it had different
names way back,
of people seeing the
structure as broken in pieces
and then connected together.
And then what did a
typical piece look like?
So a typical piece
there, well, you
let me just write down what
this matrix is going to be.
The little element matrix
is coming from spring two.
So this would be,
like element two will
be, it'll have a c_2 outside.
I'll put the c_2 outside.
And then inside will
be a little, this guy.
And we can talk more
about why it's that one.
But just to have the element
matrix there on the board.
So my claim is that this is
a small piece of the big K.
So the big K matrix, what's the
size of the big K, of K itself?
Three by three in this
case, yeah, three masses.
So it'll be three by three.
So I'm thinking that
this spring which
connects mass one to mass two,
so it's only going to be like,
a two by two piece, a little
local piece, you could say,
that that little
K fits in this--
is assembled into the-- I
better call it K_2, right?
So it's a little K that sits
up in this two by two block
and doesn't contribute
to the rest.
Then let's just draw
the rest of the picture.
So this would produce
an element matrix
that looks just the same,
that's the beauty of this.
That all the elements, apart
from change in the spring
constant, look the same.
So there'd be a little K_3.
And where will it go?
This is the whole
core to the point.
It'll go to the lower right.
Down here?
Overlapping, overlapping.
Because this mass is attached
to that spring and to that one.
So these little element
matrices, they overlap.
And you just need, if you
can imagine the code that's
going to do this, you
need a list of springs
and a list of masses and
a list of the connections
between them.
And it'll sit in here
because it's two by two.
So that's two by two,
that's two by two
and in this overlap entry will
be a c_2 from the upper box.
It'll be a c_2+c_3 as
we discovered by direct
multiplication.
So that's that spring.
Now what about
this first spring?
So there's a little K_1.
Now K_1 should look
the same as this.
Except what?
So it's going to be a difference
with this spring because?
Because of this fixed end.
There's no mass zero.
K_1 would normally sit up
here, but actually it's
only going to be one by one.
So the K_1 little element matrix
would look like c_1[1, -1; -1,
1].
And then the boundary
conditions knock those out.
And an interesting point
if you're writing big code
you have to decide.
Do I, as I create K_1,
this little element matrix,
do I pay attention to
the boundary conditions?
And then K_1 would just
be that single number
c_1 which would sit there.
So up there will be c_1
from the K_1 matrix and c_2
from the k_2 matrix.
That's the entry there.
And then, as I say, in
coding finite elements, which
you guys may do at some
point, there's a question.
What's sufficient?
Shall I pay attention
to the boundary
in creating these
element matrices
or shall I do it later?
And the rule seems
to be, do it later.
So what gets created
in finite elements
is a, in our language would
be a, free-free matrix.
It's a matrix where even this
spring has a two by two piece.
So what's the problem
with the free-free matrix?
The free-free matrices,
those with no supports,
those matrices will be singular.
Right, singular.
Because the vector
of all ones, if you
multiply the K, the
free-free matrix
times the vector of
all ones, you get zero.
The whole thing could shift.
And will have other rigid
motions in two dimensions.
Let's just think ahead here.
What are the rigid motions,
the null space of K,
you could say, for a
two-dimensional truss.
So I've got a bunch
of bars and springs.
Think of a mattress.
I'm in two
dimensions, a mattress
is a bunch of springs
connected in a 2-D grid.
And say it's free at both ends.
So what can I do to a mattress?
Oh, my gosh!
I didn't expect that
to be on videotape.
So it's in the plane.
We're in 2-D here.
What can I do if there are
no boundary conditions?
Well I can shift
it to the right.
Right?
That's our [1, 1, 1, 1, 1].
What else can I do?
I can rotate.
And I can shift
it the other way.
So there would be three rigid
motions for the 2-D problem.
Two translations and a rotation.
And when you get up
to three dimensions,
do you want to guess
what's the number in 3-D?
Six.
Number is six.
Three translations and
rotations around three axes.
So those, either one rigid
motion or three rigid motions
or six rigid
motions have to get,
the boundary
conditions eventually
have to remove those, have
to knock out rows and columns
and remove them.
But my point was just that
quite efficient to do it later.
The picture is so clear here.
So the actual
matrix would be four
by four, the unreduced matrix.
And then when we
fix node zero there,
that would knock out that part
and leave the three by three
that we want.
So this is just discussion of
how to think of this matrix K.
So the direct way
to think of it was
as a product of big matrices.
But in reality it's assembled
from these element pieces.
And of course, our goal in
talking about finite elements
will be to see that.
It'll come up again, of course.
Your good question led me there,
but did I answer the question?
And maybe the way I
mentioned it in class was
to notice that these guys,
these element matrices
can be thought of this way.
It is matrix multiplication,
but done differently.
It's a column of this
matrix times the number
c here times a row of this.
So it's matrix multiplication,
columns times rows.
So you can multiply AB,
columns of A times rows of B
and then add over,
from one to n.
So column of A times
row of B. So a column,
then, is a vector like this.
A row is a vector like that.
And the result is
a full size matrix,
but if the column
is concentrated
at a couple of nodes
and the row is,
then it will have zeroes
everywhere except at that.
This is the element matrix,
with the C included.
That would be the element matrix
already blown up to full size
by adding zeroes elsewhere.
So, I mean the heart
of the element matrix
is where the action
is on that spring.
And then, when we
assemble it, of course,
it doesn't contribute
down there.
So the technology of finite
elements is quite interesting
and it fits.
It's a beautiful way to
see the discrete problem.
Ready for another
question of any sort.
Thank you, good.
Yeah, sorry, it got
onto the problem set.
And then I thought--
let me write those words
down first, singular
value decomposition.
Well I won't write
all those words.
That's a wonderful thing.
It's a highlight of
matrix theory except
for the length of its name.
So SVD is what
everybody calls it.
It's only like, every
year now people appreciate
more and more the
importance of this SVD,
this singular value
decomposition.
So shall I say a few
words about it now?
Just a few.
So it's Section 1.7 of the book.
And my thought was, hey we've
done so much matrix theory
including eigenvalues and
positive definiteness,
let's get on and use it.
And then I can come
back to the SVD
in a sort of lighter moment.
Because I'm not
thinking you will
be responsible for the SVD.
Eigenvalues I hope
you're understanding.
Positive definite I hope
That's heart of
the course stuff.
But SVD is a key idea
in linear algebra,
but we can't do everything.
But we can say what it is.
What's the first point?
The first point is
that every matrix,
even a rectangular matrix,
has got a singular value
decomposition.
So the matrix A can be m by n.
I wouldn't speak
about the eigenvalues
of a rectangular matrix.
Because if I multiply,
you remember,
the eigenvalue equation
wouldn't make sense.
Ax=lambda*x is no good
if A is rectangular.
Right?
The input would be of
length n and the output
would be of length m
and this wouldn't work.
So eigenvectors are
not what I'm after.
But somehow the
goal of eigenvectors
was to diagonalize.
The goal of eigenvectors was to
find these special directions
in which the matrix A
just acted like a number.
And then, as we saw today in the
part that partly still up here,
we could solve equations
by eigenvectors
by looking for these,
following these special guys.
What do we do for a
rectangular matrix?
What replaces this?
So this is now not good.
The idea is simply we
need two sets of vectors.
We need some v's and some u's.
So that's the central
equation of the SVD.
Now what can we get?
So now we have more freedom
because we're getting a bunch
of v's that have,
these guys are in R^n.
They have length n, right?
To multiply A times
v, and the output
is-- so there're
n of these, n v's,
we're in n-dimensional space.
So those are called
singular vectors.
They're called right singular
vectors because they're sitting
to the right of
A. And these guys,
these outputs will be in-- these
are v's in R^n, n dimensions.
I have m of these, m u's
in m-dimensional space.
And these things are
numbers, of course.
And actually, they're all
greater or equal to zero.
So we can get, by
allowing ourselves
the freedom of
two, right singular
vectors and left singular
vectors, we can get a lot more,
and we can get,
here's the punch line.
We can get the v's to be
orthogonal, orthonormal.
Just like the eigenvectors
of a symmetric matrix,
we can get these
v's, these singular
vectors to be
perpendicular to each other
and we can get the u's to be
perpendicular to each other.
What we can't, what we're not
shooting for is the v's to be
the same as the u's.
They're not even
in the same space
now, if the matrix
A is rectangular.
And even if the matrix A is
square but not symmetric,
we wouldn't get this
perpendicularity.
But we get it in the SVD by
having different v's and u's.
Here's my picture
of linear algebra.
This is the big picture
This over here is
n-dimensional space.
We have v's.
Think of that as
n-dimensional space.
That's kind of a puny picture.
But when I multiply by
A, I take a vector here,
I multiply by A. So
let me just do that.
I multiply by A, I take a
vector v, well, I already put v,
I take Av and I get
something over here.
And this will be
the space of u's.
Now I have to ask you one
thing about linear algebra
that I keep hammering away.
If I take any vector and
multiply by A, What do I get?
If I take any vector
v, like [1,  2].
Here's A, say
[3, 6; 4, 7; 5, 8].
So that's A times
v. What can you
tell me about A times v that
goes a little deeper than just
telling me the numbers?
It's a linear combination
of the columns.
These are the outputs, the Av's.
So this space is called
the column space.
It's all combinations
of the columns.
These are all combinations
That's the column space.
It's a bunch of vectors.
So the point is that these u's,
that I have like, a fantastic
choice of axes.
A linear algebra person
would use the word, bases.
But geometrically
I'm saying they're
fantastic axes in these spaces.
So that if I choose the
right axes in the two spaces,
then one axis will go to that
one when I multiply by A.
The next one will
go to that one.
The third will go to that one.
It just could not be better.
And that's the statement.
Now maybe I'll just say a
word about where it's used
or why it's useful.
Oh, in so many applications.
Well most of you
are not biologists.
And I'm not certainly.
But we know that there's a lot
of interesting math these days
in a lot of interesting
experiments with genes.
So what happens?
So we've got about
40 people here.
And we measure the,
well, we get data.
That's what I'm
really going to say.
Somehow we got a giant
amount of data. right?.
Probably 40 columns.
Everybody here is entitled
to be a column of the matrix.
And the entries will be
like, have you got TB,
what height, all this stuff.
So you got enormous
amount of data.
And the question is, what's
important in that data.
You've got a million
entries in a giant matrix
and you want to extract
the important thing.
Well, it's the SVD that does it.
You take that giant
matrix of data,
you find the v's and
the sigmas and the u's.
And then the largest sigmas are
the most important information,
if things are scaled,
and statistics
is coming into this also.
I could a give sensible, much
more mathematical discussion
of-- One word, one
name it goes under
is principal component analysis.
That's a standard tool
for statisticians looking
at giant amounts of data.
Is to find the
principal components
and those will come
from these eigenvectors.
Well your question about the
SVD set off that discussion.
I'll only add a couple of words.
These v's and these u's
are actually eigenvectors.
But they're not eigenvectors
of A. v's happen
to be the eigenvectors
of A transpose A.
And the u's happen to be
eigenvectors of A, A transpose.
And the linear
algebra comes together
to give you this key equation.
And of course, you
and I know that if I'm
looking at the eigenvectors
v of A transpose A,
A transpose A is a
symmetric matrix.
In fact, positive definite.
So that the eigenvectors
will be orthogonal,
the eigenvalues
will be positive.
And then this one is coming
from the eigenvectors of A A
transpose, which is different.
So if the matrix A
happened to be square,
happened to be symmetric,
happened to be positive
definite, this would
just be Ax=lambda*x.
I didn't have to cross it out.
I'll use K for that.
So if the matrix A was one
of our favorite matrices,
was a K, that would be the
case in which the SVD is
no different from eigenvalues.
The v's are the same
as the u's, the sigmas
are the same as the
lambdas, all fine.
This is sort of the
way to get the beauty
of positive definite symmetric
matrices when the matrix itself
that you start with
isn't even square.
Like this one.
More than I wanted
to say, more than you
wanted to hear about the SVD.
What else?
Yes, thank you.
More about, sure.
Let me repeat the question.
So this refers to this
morning's lecture,
lecture 9 about
time-dependent problems.
And the point was that
when I have a differential
equation in time there're
lots of ways to replace it
by difference equations.
So let's take the
equation du/dt,
let's make it first order,
is some function of u, often,
and t.
That would be a first order.
Yeah, it's going to look at
when I write that much down.
What have I got?
I've got a first order
differential equation.
Is it linear?
No.
I'm allowing some, this
function of u could be sin(u).
It could be u to
the tenth power.
It could be e to the u.
So this is how
equations really come.
The linear ones are the model
problems that we can solve.
This is how linear
equations really come.
Euler thought of,
let's give Euler credit
here, so forward Euler
and backward Euler.
And the point will be
that this guy is explicit.
So can I write that word so
I don't forget to write it?
Explicit.
And that this guy
will be implicit.
And this is a big distinction.
And we'll see it.
So this says u_(n+1)-u_n
over delta t is the value
of the slope at the
start of the step.
So that's the most
important, most basic,
first thing you would think of.
It replaces this by this.
You start with u_0, and
from this you get u_1.
And then you know u_1 and
from this you get u_2.
And the point is at every step
this equation is telling you
what u_1 is from u_0.
You just move u_0
over to that side.
You've only got stuff you
know and then you know u_1.
Contrast that with
backward Euler.
So that's u_(n+1)-u_n over delta
t is f at-- Now what am I going
to put there?
I'm going to put the end,
the point we don't know yet.
So it's the slope at u_(n+1)
and the time that goes with it,
t_(n+1).
t_n is just a shorthand
for n*delta t.
n steps forward in
time got us to t_n.
This is one more step.
Now why is this called implicit?
How do I find
u_(n+1) out of this?
I've got to solve for it.
It's much more expensive.
Because it'll be probably
a non-linear system of
equations to solve.
We'll take a little
time on that.
But of course, there's
one outstanding method
to solve a system of
non-linear equations
and that's called
Newton's method.
So Newton is coming in.
Newton's method is sort of
the first, the good way,
if you can do it, to solve.
Well when I say solve, I mean
set up an iteration which,
after maybe three loops or
five loops will be accurate
to enough digits that you can
say, okay, that's u_(n+1).
On to the next step.
Then the next step will
have the same equation
but with n up one.
So it'd be u_(n+2)-u_(n+1).
So you see the extra work
here, but it's more stable.
The way this one
spiraled out, this one
spiraled in in
the model problem.
I hope you look at
that Section 2.2 which
was about the model problem
that we discussed today.
There's more to say.
I mean, this is the central
problem of time-dependent,
evolving initial value problems.
You're sort of marching forward.
But here, each step of the
march takes an inner loop
which has to work hard to solve,
to find, where you march to.
Is that a help,
to indicate what?
Because this is a very
fundamental difference.
And Chapter 6 of the book
develops higher order methods.
These are both first order,
first order accurate.
The error that you're making
is of the order of delta t.
That's not great, right?
Because you would
have to take many,
many small steps to
have a reasonable error.
So these higher
order methods allow
you to get to a great
answer with bigger steps.
A lot of thinking
has gone into that
and somehow it's a
pretty basic problem.
Just to mention
for MATLAB, ode45
is maybe the workhorse code to
solve this type of a problem.
And the method is not Euler.
That would not be good enough.
It's called Runge-Kutta.
Two guys, Runge and
Kutta, figured out
a formula that got up to
fourth order accurate.
So that's the thing.
And then if we looked
further about this subject
we would distinguish
some equations
that are called stiff.
So I'll just write
that word down.
Some equations, the iteration
is particularly difficult.
You have two time scales.
Maybe you've got things
happening on a slow scale
and a high scale.
Multi-scale computations,
that's where the subject is now.
And so there would be separate
codes with an S in their names
suitable for these tougher
problems, stiff equation.
I guess one thing you sometimes
get in the review session
is a look outside the scope
of what I can cover and ask
homework problems about.
I'm sure hoping that you're
assembling the elements
of computational science here.
First, what are the questions?
What are some answers?
What are the issues?
What do you have to balance
to make a good decision?
Time for another
question if we like.
Yeah, thank you.
Stability, yeah, right.
This here?
First, if we want
a matrix then this
has to be a vector of unknowns.
I'm thinking now of a system
of, this is n equations.
I've got u is a vector
with n components.
I've got n equations here.
The notation, I can put
a little arrow over it
just to remind myself.
And if I want to get to a matrix
I better do the linear case.
So I'll do the linear case.
The big picture is
that the new values
come from the old values.
There has to be a
matrix multiplier.
Anytime we have
a linear process.
So the new values come from
old values by some linear map.
A matrix is doing it.
So there's a sort
of growth matrix.
Can I just put down
some letters here?
I won't be able to give
you a complete answer.
But this'll do it.
So u_(n+1) is some
matrix times u_n.
That's what I wrote down this
morning for a special case.
It's gotta look like that
for a linear problem.
And let's suppose that we have
this nice situation as today
where it's the same
G at every step.
So the problem is not
changing in time, it's linear,
it's all good.
What is the solution after
n times steps compared
to the start?
So give me a simple formula
for the solution to this step,
step, step equation.
If I started at
initial value u_0
and I looked to see, well what
matrix gets me over n steps,
what do I write there?
G to the n, right, G to the n.
So now comes the question.
The stability question
is whether-- do
the powers of G to the nth grow?
And here's the point.
That the continuous problem
that this came from,
it's got its own growth
or decay or oscillation.
This guy, the discrete
one, has got its.
They're going to be
close for a step or two.
For one or two
steps I'm expecting
that this is a reasonable
consistent approximation
to my problem.
But after I take
a thousand steps,
this one could still be close
or it could have exploded.
And that's the stability thing.
The choice of the difference
method can be be stable or not.
And it's going to be the
eigenvalues of G that
are the best guide.
So in the end people compute
the eigenvalues of the growth
matrix and look to see are
they bigger than one or not.
Let's close with that example
because that's a good example.
So it fits this, but not quite,
because it wasn't completely
forward or completely backward.
And let's just write down what
it was in that model problem
and find the matrix.
So can you remind me
what I wrote today?
So u, was it u first? u_(n+1)
was u_n + delta t*v_n, right?
And then the new velocity
was the old velocity and it
should be minus
delta t times the u.
Because our equation is, these
are representing the equation--
u'=v is the first one.
v'=-u is my second equation.
So and then the
point was I could
take that because I know it
already, I could take it there.
Where is the matrix here?
I want to find the growth
matrix that tells me now--
My growth matrix, of course--
This is [u n, v n] and this is
[u (n+1), v (n+1)].
And this is a two by two matrix.
And I hope we can read it off.
Or find it anyway.
Because that's the key.
How could we get a matrix
out of these two equations?
Let me just ask
you to look at them
and think what are
we going to do.
That's a good question.
What shall I do?
I would like to know the
new u's, u, v from the old.
What'll I do?
Bring stuff onto, a u_(n+1)
on its side and n on its side.
This guy I want
to get over here.
Can I do that with erasing?
So it's going to come
over with a plus sign.
So I guess I see here an
implicit matrix acting
on the left and an explicit
matrix acting on the right.
So I see a [u n, v n].
And I see my explicit matrix.
Shall I call it E?
That's the right sides.
I see a one and a
one and a delta t.
And now my left side of my
equation, the n+1 stuff.
What's my implicit matrix on
the left sides of the equation?
Well, a one and a one and a
plus delta t is here, right?
And let's call that
I for implicit.
Are we close?
I think that looks pretty good.
What's G?
What's the matrix G now?
You just have to begin
to develop a little faith
that yeah, I can
deal with matrices,
I can move them around,
they're under my control.
I wanted this picture.
I want to move
everything to the right.
What do I do to move everything
to the right-hand side?
I want that to be over there.
It's an inverse.
It's the inverse.
So G, the matrix G there
is, I bring I over here.
It's the inverse
of I times the E.
And I can figure out
what that matrix is.
And I can find its eigenvalues.
And it'll be interesting.
So actually that's
the perfect problem.
I mean, if you want to
see what's going on,
well the book will be
a good help I think,
but that's the growth
matrix for leapfrog.
And I'll tell you the
result. The eigenvalues are
right of magnitude
one, as you hope, up
to a certain value of delta t.
And then when delta t
passes that stability
limit the eigenvalues take off.
So that this method
is great provided
you're not too ambitious and
take too large a delta t.
Thanks for that last
question, thanks for coming.